اللي ينظر للحكومة اليوم يجد صعوبة كبيرة جدًّا
في الربط ما بينها وما بين الحكومة في ذاك الوقت
صدقًا حكومة مختلفة، تمامًا
25 إبريل 2016، اعتمد مجلس الوزراء رؤية السعودية 2030
نزلت وثيقتها في الموقع الرسمي
حوار للأمير محمد مع «تركي الدخيل»
يوم للتاريخ، أوصف لي شعورك هذاك اليوم
وأيش صار بعدها؟
صدقًا كانت ثلاثة شهور عصيبة جدًّا جدًّا
مخاض عسير كان خروج رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية 2030
الفكرة كانت، أن احنا أحد أكبر مُصدرين نفط في العالم في ذاك الوقت
ليش ما نكون مُصدرين للطاقة؟
قال لي يا فهد، أنا قلت لك مناطق خاصة
وليست مناطق اقتصادية خاصة
وقتها وجدت الطرح غريب
ليش نبغى المصطلح الأعم اللي يمكن ما يوضح الصورة بالضبط
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
على مدى أكثر من 120 حلقة حكينا حكايا الرؤية
ومبادراتها ومشاريعها وأجهزتها
واليوم نحكي حكاية الرؤية نفسها
كيف ولدت؟ كيف تبلورت؟ كيف تطورت؟
كيف صُممت خططها التنفيذية؟ وكيف تتم متابعتها؟
وضيفنا لهذه الحلقة هو معالي الدكتور «فهد تونسي»
المستشار بالديوان الملكي والأمين العام لللجنة الاستراتيجية
في مجلس الشؤون الاقتصادية والتنمية
المظلة المسؤولة عن هذه الرؤية
الحلقة مميزة جدًّا
لأنها حكت كواليس ولادة هذه الرؤية
من أول مرة طُرحت الرؤى والتوجهات
إلى مرحلة تطويرها إلى وثيقة مكتوبة
ونقاشها وتحديد محاورها وتحديد ركائزها، إلى إطلاقها للمجتمع
أيش صار بعد هذا الإطلاق؟
سؤال، كيف ننفذ الرؤية؟
ماذا نتج عنه من برامج ومبادرات؟
تكلمنا عن أهم التحديات في تحقيق الرؤية
خلال السبع سنوات الماضية
أهم المتحقق في الرؤية على محاورها الثلاثة
المجتمع الحيوي والاقتصاد المزدهر والوطن الطموح
في النصف الأول من رحلتنا، اللي هي السبع سنوات الماضية
ضيفنا أكمل في هذه السنة عشر سنوات يعمل مع الأمير محمد
فكانت فرصة ذهبية أننا نتعرف
على أهم السمات القيادية للأمير محمد
ونختم فيها حوارنا المميز
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
أترككم مع الحوار
حياك الله أبو عبدالله، شرفتنا ونورتنا
شكرًا لك يا عمر، سعيد بوجودي معاك
أبو عبدالله، حتى مكان التصوير اخترت يكون على البحر
أيش قصتك مع البحر؟
البحر يمكن شيء لازمني من طفولتي
مكان أجد نفسي فيه بشكل كبير، الحمد لله
مؤخرًا صار مكان يربطني كثيرًا بعائلتي
سواء أي وقت فراغ عندي تلاقيني دائمًا
أحاول أن أكون في البحر
وأولادي يحبوا البحر من نفس الطريقة
فشيء مشترك بيننا يجمعنا
لذلك له مكانة كبير جدًّا في قلبي
وآخر الجزر وين كانت؟
آخر جزيرة رحتها كانت شمال مشروع البحر الأحمر
جزيرة عذراء، فيها نظام بيئي غريب من نوعه
مشروع البحر الأحمر عبارة عن بحيرة
تقريبًا 50 كيلو × 200 كيلو
وعندها مجموعة من فتحات التنقية، يسموها «ميزاب»
هذه الأماكن نظام بيئي بيولوجي عجيب جدًّا
لأن مع المد والجزر تفضِّي البحيرة كل يوم
وترجع تتعبى من هذه الميازيب
البحيرة طبعًا تقصد المنطقة الواسعة
اللي جزر البحر الاحمر تحيط فيها
مضبوط
بحيرات طبيعية
بحيرة طبيعية هي، شعب مرجانية
بينها في النصف بحيرة طبيعية إلى حدٍ ما
فلما تفضِّي وتملّي كل يوم؛ تخرج «العناصر الغذائية» وترجع
فبالتالي جاذبة للأسماك الكبيرة
فنظام بيئي جميل جدًّا وعجيب صراحة
أنت آخر جزيرة كنت شمال مشروع البحر الأحمر
أنا آخر جزيرة كنت في جنوب هذه البحيرة
جزيرة «شيبارة» جيت قبل أمس من مشروع البحر الأحمر
وأعتقد أن هذه أجمل جزيرة قد شفتها في حياتي
جزيرة «شيبارة» موضوع المانقروف
وأشجار المانقروف المحيطة، و تداخلها مع الرمال
وبعدين منطقة الشعب المرجانية اللي مسوية كذا
كأنها طوق حول الجزيرة
درجات المياه، شفنا درجات مياه
كان معنا في الهيليكوبتر بنت هي الوحيدة
اللي قدرت تسمي درجات المياه
لأن احنا كأولاد قاعدين نشوف أزرق، بس ماهو أزرق واحد
فيه أزرق غامق وأزرق فاتح أفتح من الفاتح
كان منظر جبار جدًّا
أنت أبو عبدالله، أمين مجلس إدارة البحر الأحمر وللا لا؟
صحيح
مرة متحمسين لهذا المشروع
والله وأنا متحمس جدًّا جدًّا لهذا المشروع
أعتقد أنه بيحدث نقلة نوعية في المعروض للسياحة الداخلية
السائح السعودي نشأ وكبر أن عنده فرصة
أن يشوف أفضل أماكن في العالم، وعنده الخيار
فكان التحدي الحقيقي بالنسبة لقطاع السياحة في المملكة
أن احنا نوفر خيارات تنافس أفضل ماهو موجود في العالم
أنا أعتقد أن مشروع البحر الأحمر في هذا الفئة من المشاريع
بإذن الله
طبعًا من بين عشرات القبعات، اللي الله يعطيك العافية
قاعد تتولاها، احنا اليوم نتكلم على قبعة مميزة ومهمة
وذات ارتباط وثيق ببودكاست سقراط
قبعة أمين عام اللجنة الاستراتيجية
في مجلس الشؤون الاقتصادية والتنمية
اللي هي مسؤولة عن الرؤية بشكل عام
احنا صورنا أكثر من 120 حلقة مع قادة التحول
نحكي حكايا الرؤية
اليوم حان الوقت أننا نحكي حكاية الرؤية نفسها
من ولادتها كفكرة إلى تطوراتها، إلى أين وصلنا اليوم فيها
فمن وين تحب تبدأ؟
أفضل نقطة للبداية، هو الاجتماع الأول لمجلس الاقتصاد والتنمية
منذ أن تولى الملك سلمان، الله يحفظه، سدة الحكم
كان أحد أول القرارات اللي اُتخذت
إلغاء عدد المجالس اللي كانت موجودة وقائمة، اثنا عشر مجلس
وبعدين إنشاء المجلسين
وهذا كان أول لقاء لك مع الأمير، وللا كان فيه شيء قبله؟
لا، أنا قبلها كنت أعمل مدير إدارة المجالس واللجان
في ديوان سمو ولي العهد
انضميت للعمل في عام نهاية 2012 وبداية 2013
كمدير لإدارة اللجان والمجالس
اللي كان الملك سلمان وقت ما كان ولي عهد
في ذاك الوقت يرأس مجالسها
اُستقطبت للعمل من خلال عملية استقطاب محترفة صراحةً
شركة تكلمت معايا
وطلبوني لعمل مقابلة مع سمو ولي العهد
وفي وقتها سمو رئيس ديوان ولي العهد الأمير محمد
وبدأت العمل من هناك
كان هذا أول لقاء معه؟
هذا كان أول لقاء مع سمو الأمير محمد
أيش تذكر من هذاك اللقاء؟
لأن هذا اللقاء قبل تولّي الملك سلمان
وقبل إعلان رؤية بشكل رسمي
فأكيد فيه كواليس وفيه إرهاصات بيّنت من ذاك اللقاء
دخلت على طويل العمر في مكتبه
في ديوان ولي العهد في ذاك الوقت
موقف مهيب، مكان مبهر بدون أدنى شك
بس الأهم من هذا، كله كان لقاء سُموّه نفسه
كان مبهر لأبعد حد
بدأ بطريقة تقليدية، مقابلة مثل أي مقابلة في أي مكان ثاني
بعد كذا وصلنا لمفترق الطريق
سُموّه، سألني بعض الأسئلة عن تاريخي المهني
أعمالي السابقة، اطلع على السيرة الذاتية وما إلى ذلك
وبعدين عرض عليّ العمل
أنا داخل أصلًا متردد، وأبغى فرصة أن أنا أفكر في الموضوع
فكان مفاجئ جدًّا بالنسبة لي السؤال هذا
كان لازم أرد في وقتها
فبدأت أسأل، ليش أنضم إلى العمل الحكومي؟
هنا صراحة نشوف جانب مبهر من سُموّه، الله يحفظه
كان أول شيء، مستشعر لكل التحديات اللي في البلد
صريح جدًّا في طرحها، وكان الله يحفظه، فيه شجاعة مختلفة في الطرح
ورغبة في التغيير من مكان قيادي
صراحة فكرت في نفسي إذا شفت هذا الأمر
وما سعيت أن أحاول أن أدعم هذا الفكر المستنير في وقتها
أكون مقصّر في حق بلدي
فكان بداية الانضمام لهذا السبب
وكان فيه توافق فكري عالي جدًّا
أنا في القطاع الخاص كنت أعمل في مجال حوكمة الشركات
الحوكمة في القطاع العام في المملكة عندنا ما كانت موجودة
فكونها جهة حكومية سيادية
تتكلم عن حوكمة مجالس ولجان؛ بالنسبة لي كانت جديد
حتى القطاع الخاص في ذاك الوقت
ترى ما كان مرة متقدم في هذه المعايير
هيئة سوق المال هي اللي فرضتها
وبدأت تنشرها وزارة التجارة كذلك
لكن في 2012 و2013 حتى القطاع الخاص مو كله يحكي لغة الحوكمة
صحيح. القطاع الخاص لو ما كانت جهود هيئة سوق المال
في أن هي تفرض الأمر هذا بشكل أو بآخر
ولا ننسى فيه جانب المستثمر
المستثمر يرغب في الحوكمة، فكان فيه دعم
لكن القطاع الحكومي أيش يدفعه أن يسوي حوكمة؟
إلا وجود فكر مستنير من فوق
كان واجب وطني أن أنضم
والحقيقة، خير أحمد الله عليه إلى اليوم
وبعد سنتين من العمل، ما قبل تولي الملك سلمان، الله يحفظه
في بداية توليه، بعد أقل من أسبوع
صدر قرار تشكيل مجلسين
مجلس شؤون الاقتصادية والتنمية
ومجلس الشؤون السياسية والأمنية
وعُقد أول اجتماع، أنت كنت موجود في أول اجتماع
حدثني عن كواليسه
أول اجتماع يا طويل العمر
أول شيء، هذه المجلسين تأسيسها هو مؤشر لتغيير كبير جدًّا
في عمل الحكومة
ليش؟
اللي هو إنشاء مركز حكومة قوي
مركز الحكومة في العالم عادةً له دور محوري
في وضع السياسات والتوجهات ومتابعة التنفيذ
هذا الشيء كان ماهو موجود عندنا
في المملكة العربية السعودية بشكل موازي للطموح
فإنشاء المجلسين بحد ذاتها، هذا كان إشارة للتغير في هذا الاتجاه
أول اجتماع لمجلس الشؤون الاقتصادية والتنمية
كان اجتماع استثنائي بكل المقاييس
أول شيء، عشان نستشعر الموقف
وزراء كثير منهم جداد، يمكن غالبيتهم كانوا جداد في ذاك الوقت
بعضهم حتى ما يعرف بعض
والمجلس أول مرة ينعقد
فكثير منهم غائب عنه الهدف من إنشاء هذا المجلس
جاوا كلهم على الاجتماع
وكل الناس ماهي عارفة أيش المطلوب وليش
وكيف بنشتغل، وما إلى ذلك
بدأ الاجتماع برئاسة سُموّه، الله يحفظه
والحقيقة بدايته كانت بكلمة من سمو الأمير في البداية
وضّح فيها الهدف من إنشاء المجلس هذا
وطمأن الجميع أن هذا المكان
الهدف الأساسي منه هو وضع السياسة العامة
من خلال الحوار والتشاور والحوار المفتوح
أتذكر أنه لما بدأ، قال احنا حطينا هذا المجلس
عشان نعزز فكرة تبادل الأفكار ما بين الوزراء
فالنقاش كان مفتوح من أول يوم
يطرح سُموّه رأي، يطرح أحد الوزراء رأي
ونسمع الرأي والرأي الآخر
فكان جميل جدًّا، لكن هذا المجلس بالذات اللي يميز عن غيره
أو هذه الجلسة بالذات اللي يميزها عن غيرها
كانت أول مرة تطرح ما سُميّ لاحقًّا بالتوجهات والرؤى
اللي هي فكر وتوجهات الحكومة الجديدة في عهد الملك سلمان
نحو القطاعات المختلفة
في الزراعة نبغى كذا، في التجارة نبغى كذا
وكان سُموّه الله يحفظه، يطرح الفكرة
وينادي الوزير باسمه، يا فلان، في مجال الزراعة نبغى كذا وكذا
في مجال التجارة نبغى كذا وكذا
وبعدين يسمع منه، ويسمع أراء باقي الوزراء
في الملف اللي يخص هذا الوزير
فكان الحوار شفاف جدًّا
الاطروحات كانت جديدة في كثير من الأحيان
كان طرح مختلف وكان أسلوب مختلف في طرح الأمور
تذكر أمثلة من الملفات اللي ناقشها
أو شرح تطلعاته للوزير المعني؟
الأمثلة كثيرة، الأمثلة في أكثر من مجال
كان من ضمن التساؤلات مثلًا
أنا أتذكر سمو الأمير، الله يحفظه، قال
صار لنا خمسين سنة ننتج نفط، والنفط يشكّل 90% من دخلنا
فمتى بننوّع اقتصادنا؟
ومتى بنبدأ نخفف من اعتمادنا الكبير على النفط؟
لأن هو سوق متقلب الأسعار
وبالتالي ما تقدر تخطط على أسعار متقلبة
من ضمن الطروحات اللي كانت جديدة
في ذاك الوقت بالنسبة لنا، مثلًا
موضوع الطاقة المتجددة؟
موضوع الطاقة المتجددة
الفكرة كانت أن احنا أحد أكبر مُصدرين نفط في العالم في ذاك الوقت
ليش ما نكون مُصدرين للطاقة؟
فننظر إلى الطاقة المتجددة، وننظر إلى مش بس تصدير النفط
وإنما تصدير الكهرباء ومدخلات الطاقة الجديدة
مثل الهيدروجين وما إلى ذلك
التفاصيل اللي صارت في الاجتماع هذاك مبهرة
تخلي عندي فضول أكثر أتعرّف عليه
لأن كل الوزراء اللي قابلتهم وتحدثنا عن هذا الاجتماع
كانوا يتكلمون على دقة في وضوح الرؤية
كان يقولون أنه كان يحكي مع وزير العدل في الخدمات العدلية
نبغى كذا كذا، ثم يستدرك ويقول
مع الحفاظ على استقلال القضاء ككيان مستقل
بس نتكلم عن الخدمات العدلية لازم يكون كذا وكذا
في الزراعة، في المياه، في التجارة
في خدمات التنمية الاجتماعية والشؤون الاجتماعية
السؤال اللي عندي، احنا نتكلم عن فبراير 2015
الملك سلمان، الله يحفظه، ما كمّل وقتها شهر متولي مقاليد الحكم
فمتى أمدى الأمير محمد يلم بهذه المعلومات
يستحضرها ويبني هذه التطلعات، متى أمداه؟
أنا أعتقد وأكاد أجزم أن سمو الأمير محمد
ما بنى هذه الرؤى والتطلعات في وقتها
ولا في الأيام القليلة السابقة من خلال تحضير بسيط
لا ننسى، الأمير محمد شاب سعودي عايش في البلد هذه
ومستشعر للتحديات الموجودة ومستشعر للفرص
اللي ممكن أن هي تتحقق
في تصوري الشخصي، أن هذا الطرح تكوّن على مدى فترة طويلة جدًّا
في ذهن سُموّه، الله يحفظه
يمكن بدأ يتبلور ويظهر بالشكل اللي كان بيظهر به في ذاك الاجتماع
لكنه ماهو وليد اللحظة بكل تأكيد
وأظن يمكن يخدم موضوع سنتين في هيئة الخبراء
مطبخ الأنظمة والقرارات
فكل شيء قاعد يمر، فيبان نقاط التعثر ونقاط التأخر
وكذلك سنتين في إمارة الرياض
مع الملك سلمان، وقتها أمير الرياض
فكل المشاكل والقضايا حق المواطنين، حق التجار
حق الجهات الحكومية، قاعدة تمر أيضًا على إمارة الرياض
فهذه أتوقع نقطتين ممكن يكون فيها
الكثير من التعرف على الواقع
وملامسة نقاط الألم أو فرص التحسين اللي موجودة
بدون أدنى شك، خبرة سُموّه العملية السابقة
كانت ماهي متركزة في مجال واحد
وإنما كانت في أماكن مثل ما تفضلت
إمارة الرياض، هيئة الخبراء
أماكن تصب فيها كثير جدًّا من المواضيع
فأعطته معرفة واطلاع كبير جدًّا
أنا أتصور الكلام هذا
أعطته اطّلاع كبير جدًّا على عدد كبير جدًّا من القضايا والمشاكل
اللي تلامس حياة المواطن العادي
بالإضافة إلى ذلك، الملك سلمان حتى أيام ما كان أمير للرياض
الله يعطيه الصحة والعافية، رجل مطّلع
ورجل حريص أن يكون أبناؤه مطلعين كذلك
الأمير محمد يمكن أكثر واحد شفنا هذا الموضوع معاه
وانعكس بشكل واضح جدًّا على الرؤى والتوجهات اللي سمعناها
تعبّر عن فهم عميق لاحتياجات البلد واحتياجات المواطن
مقرونة بطموحه العالي، الله يحفظه
كم كانت مدة اجتماعكم الأول؟
عشان تناقش كل هذه وتطرحها
وتسمع من الآخرين، كم قعدتوا؟
ساعات، ما أذكر بالضبط كم ساعة، لكنها كانت ساعات
تتكلم عن أكثر من أربع أو خمس ساعات
يمكن في الحدود هذه
البدايات، كانت الاجتماعات دائمًا طويلة
الناس لسه ما تعرف بعض، بنسمع الطروحات كلها المختلفة
الأفكار في بدايات بلورتها
فكان كثير منها جلسات عصف ذهني
أكثر من أنها اجتماع
أكثر من أنه اجتماع للقرارات
أيش صار بعد هذا الاجتماع؟
اللي صار بعد هذا الاجتماع، الله يحفظه، وجّه الوزراء اللي...
أول شيء، خرجت مجموعة من الرؤى والتوجهات
أتذكرها في ذاك الوقت، كانت حوالي أربعة وعشرين مختلفة
طُلب من كل وزير أن يبني خطة لتحقيق هذه الرؤى والتوجهات
ويرجع يطرحها في الاجتماع
اجتماع المجلس ذاك الوقت كان بشكل أسبوعي
وبدأوا الوزراء يفكروا في الطروحات  الموجودة على الطاولة
وكيف ممكن تحقيقها
وبدأت تنشأ بدايات لخطط تنفيذ، خلينا نقول
هذا كله مخاض، ماهو ولادة الرؤية
لكن هذا المخاض ما قبل الولادة
فبدأ كل وزير يحط شيء من الخطة
وعرض عن آليات التنفيذ الممكنة لهذه الرؤى والتوجهات
ويرجع يعرضها في المجلس وتُطرح للنقاش
الجميل في الأمر، أن النقاش ما كان من الوزير فقط
لسمو رئيس المجلس، وإنما كان كل الوزراء الثانيين اللي عندهم رؤيات
لأن اليوم العمل الحكومي أصبح معقد جدًّا
ما في مجال واحد ينظم من قِبل جهة وحدة
بتلاقي أي عمل سواءً تجاري أو اجتماعي
دائمًا بتلاقي أكثر من جهة تشترك قيه
فالمجلس كان ممكّن لهذا الحوار بشكل كبير مرة
وأتذكر كان يقول معالي «محمد الجدعان»
طبعًا هو ما حضر البداياته
هو أصبح وزير المالية في السنة اللي بعدها
لكن تكلم عن أن في البدايات كان فيه شوية حساسية
من أن تُعطي رأي في وزارة زميلك الوزير
وممكن ياخذها بشكل شخصي
بس الثقافة هذه بدأت تترسخ وتتتبت
لدرجة أن اليوم صار النقاش مفتوح جدًّا وبأريحية
ممكن أناقش وزارتك، أعترض على تصرفاتها
بل أعطي توصيات وملاحظات على عملك أنت يا زميلي الوزير
بدون ما تؤخذ بحساسية
أصبح على وصفه، تطبيق لمفهوم أن الوزراء كلهم مسؤولين بالتضامن
أمام الملك والقيادة
فلاحظت أنت هذه التطورات في الثقافة
قاعدة تصير في الاجتماعات؟
اللي ينظر للحكومة اليوم يجد صعوبة كبيرة جدًّا
في الربط ما بينها وما بين الحكومة في ذاك الوقت
صدقًا حكومة مختلفة، تمامًا
كانت الحكومة تعمل بشكل أو بآخر، بطريقة جزر متفرقة
اليوم أصبحت فيه سياسة عامة تجمع الكل
وهدف مشترك واحد يجمع الكل
ومطلوب من الجميع، مو مرغوب، مطلوب من الجميع
أن هو يساهم في صنع هذه السياسة العامة
لأنه بشكل أو بآخر أما يؤثر فيها أو يتأثر بها
وهذه الرؤى المختلفة اللي كل وزير بدأ يشتغل على وزارته
كيف تحولت إلى الرؤية اللي نعرفها وشفناها بشكل رسمي؟
مرت بأكثر من مرحلة حقيقةً
بدأت بالرؤى والتوجهات، ثم خطط الوزراء
ثم بعد كذا عُمل ما يسمى بورش تحول الوطني
هذه الورش كانت تقودها وزارة الاقتصاد والتخطيط
تجمع الجهات الحكومية المختلفة
من وزارات وهيئات ومؤسسات عامة
لمساعدتهم على وضع خطط تنفيذ لهذا الأمر بشكل أو بآخر
اجتمعوا على مدى ثلاث شهور إذا ما كنت غلطان
وكانت ورش صراحة ديناميكية جدًّا
وعززت مبدأ التشاركية في العمل
وعززت مبدأ التضامن في تحمل المسئولية
لكن كذلك كان فيه دائمًا مبدأ القبيل، الشخص المسؤول عن الملف
فعززت مبادئ إدارية جميلة
بعد ثلاثة شهور تقريبًا من ورش العمل هذه
خرجت بوثيقة كبيرة اللي هي مخرجات ورش التحول الوطني
كانت تعبّر عن مبادرات الجهات الحكومية المختلفة
وما ترغب في تحقيقه
كان سمو ولي العهد، الله يحفظه، له مساهمة كبيرة في الموضوع هذا
خاصةً في تغيير الفكر
خاصةً في رفع الطموحات وتعزيز الثقة بالذات
أن احنا نقدر نحقق أكثر
وبعدين جات على طاولة مجلس الاقتصاد والتنمية
لما وضعت الوثيقة هذه على الطاولة
سمو الأمير، الله يحفظه، كان يقول
فيه محور ناقص، فيه شيء ناقص في هذه الوثيقة
كان يرغب، الله يحفظه، في وثيقة توضّح الوجهة العامة للكل
وتضع، كان يسميها استراتيجية في ذاك الوقت
ماهي مبادرة ، ماهو أنا أبغى أسوي الشغلة الفلانية
عشان أوصل إلى المكان الفلاني، وإنما ماهو الهدف الأسمى
وين أبغى أوصل
وين أبغى أروح
وجّه، الله يحفظه، في نهاية هذا الاجتماع
أن تشكّل لجنة من مجموعة من الوزراء، كانوا خمسة وزراء
وهذه اللجنة كانت مسؤوليتها بلورة وتطوير
هذه الوثيقة اللي لسه ما تسمّت
صحيح. لا ننسى أن تحقيق رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية
ماهو مسؤولية الحكومة بس، هو مسؤولية كل من يعيش
على تراب هذا الوطن
من حكومة، من قطاع خاص، من قطاع ثالث، من مواطنين بصفة عامة
فكنا في حاجة لحشد هذه الجهود مع بعضها
إذا أنا آخذ مبادرة الجهة
طيب الباقي أيش يجلس يسوي؟ يتفرج؟
كان لازم وثيقة معينة تحشد كل الجهود هذه
صاحب المبادرة أو الجهة المسؤولة عنها؛ ينفّذ المبادرة
لكن الباقيين أكيد فيه أساليب يقدروا يساعدوه
حتى ما كنا نعرف هي وثيقة وللا شيء ثاني، في ذاك الوقت
فأول سؤال كان، كيف نوجد الرابط المشترك ما بين هذه المبادرات
ونصيغ ما سمّي أصلًا بالرؤى والتوجهات في شكل مخرج حكومي؟
فكان هذا أول سؤال
والنتيجة كانت بمنتهى الوضوح في ذاك الوقت
هي وثيقة في بعض الحكومات سموها قائمة
بعض الحكومات تسميها التوجهات الحكومية
وقتها حتى ما كان عندنا لها اسم، الاسم وُضع بعدين
أيش اللي صار؟ أيش كانوا يسوون بالضبط الخمسة أعضاء
أو اللجنة هذه أيش كانت تسوي بالضبط؟
هل كان نقاش مفتوح؟ وللا كانت مواضيع محددة كل مرة تناقشونها
وللا عصف ذهني؟ أيش كانت تسوي اللجنة هذه بالضبط؟
اللجنة هذه أخذت مخرجات ورش التحول الوطني
بس الأهم منها، أخذت الرؤى والتوجهات الأربع وعشرين الأصلية
وبدأت تحاول توجد الرابط المشترك ما بينها
بدأنا بعدد من المقارنات المعيارية
كنا نحاول نشوف أفضل الممارسة العالمية في المجال هذا، أيش كانت
استعننا بعدد من الشركات الاستشارية
اللي اشتغلت مع حكومات أخرى في العالم
عشان نستفيد من دروس من سبقنا
ما كنا نشتغل مع شركة استشارية وحدة
كنا حريصين أن نشتغل مع أكثر من شركة استشارية
لغرض التأكد من المخرجات اللي توصلنا
إلى أن وصلنا إلى درجة عالية جدًّا من اليقين
أن أغلب دول العالم تركز دائمًا على ثلاثة محاور رئيسية
اقتصادي، اجتماعي ومكانة دولية بشكل عام
كانت اللجنة تجتمع بشكل يومي
وبعدين بشكل أسبوعي يجتمع مجلس الشؤون الاقتصادية والتنمية
برئاسة سمو سيدي، الله يحفظه
ويُطرح ما توصلت إليه اللجنة هذه على طاولة المجلس
يناقش بشكل عميق جدًّا، في حوار مفتوح جميل حقيقة
هذه الأيام ما أنساها، لأنه كانت الحوارات فيها جميلة جدًّا
فيه أراء مبنية على خبرات عميقة لوزارات
وبعدين فيه أراء، أحيانًا فيه وزير ما يعرف عن رأي الوزارة الأخرى
لكنه كمواطن عنده رأي في الموضوع هذا
حتى هذا كان يُسمع بشكل كبير جدًّا
وكان سُموّه، حريص على أن هذا النقاش مستمر في المجلس
أنا أذكر أحيانًا بعض الوزراء ما كان يدلي بدلوه في بعض الأمور
لكن سُموّه يعرف من خلال حواراته الخاصة، أن فلان له رأي
كان يسأل، يا فلان أيش رأيك في الموضوع الفلاني
أحيانًا مواضيع يكون لها جوانب متعددة ما طُرحت كلها
فحريص دائمًا أن الجانب المالي يطرح رأيه
الجانب الاقتصادي يطرح رأيه
وجانب الممكنات من موارد بشرية أو أنظمة تقنية
أو ما إلى ذلك كمان يطرح رأيه
فكان حوار جميل جدًّا في المجلس
تجتمع اللجنة بشكل يومي، يجتمع المجلس بشكل أسبوعي
يُقبل أو يرفض الطرح اللي طرحته اللجنة في ذاك الوقت
وبعد كذا يعدل عليه
واستمر الموضوع هذا لمدة ثلاثة أشهر
إلى أن خرج المجلس بوثيقة رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية 2030
وبناءً على الممارسات العالمية
أنتوا توصلتوا للمحاور الثلاثة حق الرؤية
صحيح
اللي هي: مجتمع حيوي، اقتصاد مزدهر، وطن طموح
طيب الركائز حق الرؤية؟
كان سُموّه في بداية الطرح دائمًا يتكلم عن وثيقة استراتيجية
الاستراتيجيات دائمًا تبنى على أما نقاط ضعف حابين أن نحسنها
أو نقاط قوة حابين أن نركز عليها
وكان دائمًا يتساءل عن هذه الأمور
وترى ماهو سهل أن تفكر في نقاط قوتك
سهل جدًّا توجِد نقاط ضعفك
فأتذكر طرح سُموّه في ذاك الوقت، كان يقول
احنا قلب العالم العربي والإسلامي
احنا قوة استثمارية رائدة
وفي نفس الوقت، موقعنا جغرافي مكان يتوسط
قارات العالم الثلاثة القديمة
هذا الطرح اللي كان مثلًا التحدي رقم اثنين عند اللجنة هذه
هل هذه فعلًا نقاط قوتنا؟
هل نقدر نلاقي نقاط قوة أقوى منها؟
صدقًا ما كان فيه أقوى منها
وفي الأخير صارت هي الركائز هذه
فكان سُموّه حريص أن عمل اللجنة هذه يكون مبني
على أسس بناء الاستراتيجية بالطريقة العلمية
المتعارف عليها في العالم
من هنا جاءت ركائز القوة
احنا نتكلم على رؤية ما قبل إعلانها للناس بكامل محتوياتها
نعم
هل رُوجعت وللا اُعتمد على الملفات اللي تم قبولها وطلعت للناس
كيف كانت تُراجع محتويات الوثيقة النهائية للرؤية؟
طبعًا المراجعة ما تمت على مرحلة وحدة
احنا قلنا فيه لقاءات يومية ثم فيه لقاءات أسبوعية
في اللقاء الأسبوعي هذا كانت تُطبع المحتويات
اللي توصلت إليها اللجنة هذه
وتوضع على طاولة مجلس الاقتصاد والتنمية
أمام كل وزير فيه نسخة ورقية مكتوبة قدامه
ندخل المجلس، يجلس سُموّه، الله يحفظه
ويجلسوا الوزراء على الطاولة
كل واحد يقرأ كلمة، كلمة
يُعدّل، يبدي رأي، يبدل فيها وما إلى ذلك
والتعديلات تصير على الفور، ناخذ التعديلات
نجي الأسبوع اللي بعده نورّيه التعديلات حق الأسبوع الماضي
وفي نفس الوقت، أي طرح جديد موجود على الطاولة
أتذكر هذه الاجتماعات كان فيها شيء من الغرابة
سمو الأمير، الله يحفظه، معروف هذا الشيء عنه
ويمكن كثير من الناس يعرفوه
سريع جدًّا جدًّا، الله يحفظه ويبارك له
ما شاء الله تبارك الله عليه
فكان دائمًا يسبق كل الوزراء في القراءة وفي التعديل
وقرأها كلمة، كلمة وخلّص وجالس يستنى الباقين
فكان فيه صمت غريب في القاعة كذا
أن الناس كلها قاعدة تقرأ
وسمو الأمير قاعد ينتظر انتهاءهم من القراءة
وكان، الله يحفظه، يعطي الناس مجال
ما يبدأ الحوار إلا لما يخلّص آخر واحد القراءة
وبعد كذا يبدأ النقاش المفتوح على المحتوى
تتذكر موضوع صار عليه نقاش أوشيء
وقتها أنت ما كنت مقتنع فيه، بعدين اتضح لاحقًّا
أي من كواليس هذيك الاجتماعات؟
أول شيء، ما فيه موضوع ماطُرح للنقاش المكثف
فصعب أن أنا أتذكر موضوع واحد
يمكن فيه نقطة وحدة أرجع لك عليها
بس قبل ما أتكلم عنها
الجديد بالنسبة للكل في هذا الحوار كان
ديناميكية ما بين رغبة سمو الأمير، الله يحفظه
في رفع الطموح في كل مجال
كان حريص أن نوصل لأقصى حد طموح ممكن
يمكن حتى نقرّب شوية من حد الغير ممكن
لكن دائمًا يرفع مستوى الطموح لأقصى حد ممكن
ولا ننسى الطاولة الديناميكية اللي موجودة عليها
إذا عندك القائد اللي بيضع التوجّه
ويضع المستهدف بشكل كبير
وبعدين فيه الوزير المسؤول عن التنفيذ
فالحوار اللي ما بينهم
واحد بيحط الطموح والثاني مسؤول عن تحقيقه
كانت ديناميكية جديدة بالنسبة لنا
وأعتقد نتيجة هذا الأمر هو مستوى الطموح اللي بنشوفه اليوم
هذا ما كان موجود في السابق
كان عندنا قدرة عالية جدًّا، لكننا كنا راضيين
بمستويات أداء أقل من ذلك
فهذا كان أحد الأشياء الجميلة
يمكن موقف معين أتذكره في الحوارات الأسبوعية هذه
كان سمو الأمير، الله يحفظ، استخدم مصطلح المناطق الخاصة
لما جيت أكتبه في الوثيقة كتبت المناطق الاقتصادية الخاصة
لأن هذا المصطلح المتعارف عليه دوليًّا
رجع قال لي أنا قلت مناطق خاصة، مو مناطق اقتصادية خاصة
أخذت الملاحظة ورجعت، بدأت أعمل بحث
سألت، لقيت أن مصطلح المناطق الخاصة هذا مصطلح عام جدًّا
ماهو متعارف عليه، ووقتها احنا كنا بنتكلم أصلًا
عن المناطق الاقتصادية الخاصة
فرجعت الأسبوع اللي بعده، وكتبت مناطق اقتصادية خاصة
قال لي فهد، أنا قلت لك مناطق خاصة، وليست مناطق اقتصادية خاصة
وقتها وجدت الطرح غريب
ليش نبغى المصطلح الأعم اللي يمكن ما يوضّح الصورة بالضبط
لكن اليوم نقدر نشوف الكلام هذا بوضوح على أرض الواقع
عندنا مناطق اقتصادية خاصة، عندنا مناطق لوجستية خاصة
عندنا مناطق حوسبة سحابية خاصة
أشكال متنوعة من المناطق الخاصة
يتضح لي بكل تأكيد أن سُموّه، الله يحفظه
في ذاك الوقت كان مستشرف هذا المستقبل وشايفه قدامه
هذا كان بالنسبة لي افتتاحية عالية في 2016
ما أحد يفكر بهذا الفكر صراحةً
حوارات كانت جميلة جدًّا. وأعتقد التاريخ لازم يسجلها
25 إبريل 2016 اعتمد مجلس وزراء رؤية السعودية 2030
نزلت وثيقتها في الموقع الرسمي
حوار للأمير محمد مع «تركي الدخيل»
يوم للتاريخ، أوصف لي شعورك في ذاك اليوم
وأيش صار بعدها؟
صدقًا كانت ثلاثة شهور عصيبة جدًّا
مخاض عسير كان خروج رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية 2030
بعد ما خرجت الوثيقة مباشرة
أنا بالنسبة لي كنت بحاجة ماسة إلى الراحة
المبهر في الموضوع كان السرعة في الانتقال
من مرحلة التخطيط لمرحلة التنفيذ
مجرد ما خرجت الرؤية والعالم انبهر بها في ذاك الوقت
انعقد مجلس الاقتصاد والتنمية
وبدأت التساؤلات عن كيف نحقق هذا الأمر
وقتها اللي كان مطروح على الطاولة
كان برنامج التوازن المالي وبرنامج التحول الوطني
التوازن المالي وقتها كان اللي اليوم اسمه الاستدامة المالية
صحيح
كان التوازن المالي في ذلك الوقت
يمكن هذه نقطة نحتاج نرجع لها في وقت لاحق
إيه بجيها
اللي هو الديناميكية في التنفيذ
ما ينفع أن أنت تكتب قواعدك وتصمم عليها
وهذه نقطة تستاهل حقيقة نرجع لها في وقت لاحق
في ذيك اللحظة وصلتوا إلى التحول الوطني
كمظلة لكل الجهات الحكومية تقريبًا
والتوازن المالي كالجزء المالي والتعامل مع العجز
ومبادرات إدارة المال العام
هذه هي البرنامجين لتحقيق الرؤية كانت
صحيح إلى حد كبير جدًّا، لكن ما تغطي كل محاور الرؤية
ما تغطي كل المستهدفات اللي مطلوب تحقيقها من الرؤية
فكان سُموّه، الله يحفظه، يقول عندنا برنامجين اليوم
مطروحة على الطاولة، أيش نحتاج برامج ثانية؟
وقتها كان فيه تساؤل عن مرجعية التنفيذ
هل فيه جهة مسؤولة وللا الكل مسؤول بالتضامن
وبطريقة مفتوحة جدًّا؟
أفضل ممارسات العالمية لتحقيق رؤية بهذا الحجم
أن أنت تحتاج جهة مركزية تكون مسؤولة عن وضع آليات التنفيذ
سن السياسات اللازمة لذلك
متابعة التنفيذ بعد ذلك
والتعديل بشكل ديناميكي ومستمر
الطرح اللي طُرح في وقتها
كان إنشاء مكتب إدارة استراتيجية في مركز الحكومة
وهذا تعزيز آخر للدور المحوري لمركز الحكومة
بعد صدور الرؤية بحوالي شهر تقريبًا
أُنشئ مكتب الإدارة الاستراتيجية، وأنشئت اللجنة الاستراتيجية
التابعة لمجلس الشؤون الاقتصادية والتنمية
برئاسة سمو سيدي ولي العهد، الله يحفظه
وأنت توليت أمانتها
وأنا توليت أمانة اللجنة هذه
ورئاسة المكتب
ورئاسة المكتب في ذاك الوقت
وبدأ العمل على أيش البرامج الثانية اللي نحتاجها
عشان نقدر نحقق رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية 2030
احنا كمكتب كنا حريصين أن نركز جهودنا قدر المستطاع
وكنا حريصين صدقًا أنه ما يتجاوز عدد البرامج خمسة في ذاك الوقت
كنا نقول أن خمسة هو الرقم السحري
اللي المفروض أن نحن نحاول نلتزم عليه، لأنه يمكن الحكم فيه
مع ذلك حجم الطموح، وحجم التحول المطلوب وتنوع المجالات
لأنها بتغطي كل المجالات المهمة بالنسبة للوطن
سُموّه، ما قبل مننا هذا الطرح، وبدأ يطرح طروحات بديلة
وصلنا إلى ثلاثة عشر برنامج في ذاك الوقت
اللي اليوم وصلت إلى إحدى عشر برنامج
المكتب في ذاك الوقت أول ما بدأ
أتذكر كنا حوالي خمسة عشر أو ستة عشر شاب سعودي طموح
كلهم جايين من خلفيات مهنية ممتازة، بوظائف جيدة
قبل إنشاء المكتب ما كان فيه كيان مؤسسي يحتضنهم
كلهم تركوا وظائف ممتازة حقيقةً
أقدر أقول رموا نفسهم وراء الرؤية هذه
لأنهم شافوا فيها مستقبل الوطن
فكان جميل جدًّا الموضوع هذا
أنا برجع لموضوع التنفيذ، لأنه يستاهل نستفيض فيه شوية
هو أظنه العلامة الفارقة بين الرؤية وبين بقية مشاريع التحول
في أي مكان آخر
الكل يقدر يسوي رؤية، بس مين يقدر ينفذها
فأظن هذه بنسولف فيها أكثر
بشكل عام فترة التواصل عن الرؤية دائمًا
توصف بأنها تواصل نخبوي
يخاطب شريحة أعلى 5% في المجتمع
اللي هم يجيدوا لغة المؤشرات والمستهدفات والمبادرات
لكنها ماهي قادرة توصل لعموم المجتمع
لطلاب الجامعة، للأطفال، للوافدين، المقيمين عندنا
أيش تعليقك على هذه النقطة؟
يمكن يكون هذا الكلام صحيح
لكن اللي حصل من وقتها إلى الآن شيئين
1% إلى- 5% هذه ترى صارت 95%
لذلك اليوم لما تتكلم حتى على مستوى الشارع
يتكلم على مستهدفات ويتكلم على مؤشرات الأداء
لذلك لغة الرؤية أخذت وقتها
عشان توصل لمستوى الشارع، هذا واحد
والشيء الثاني، بدأت قصص النجاح تنساب
وتبدأ تلامس المواطن
فصار المواطن هو اللي يتكلم عن قصة النجاح
كيف أنا اليوم أقدر أن أعمل جلسة محكمة بطريقة إلكترونية
أنا آسف، بس هذه قصة أقوى كثيرًا من أن أنا أتكلم
عن تعزيز تقديم الخدمات العدلية و ما إلى ذلك
صحيح
قس على ذلك الكثير طبعًا
النقطة الثانية، أنا أتذكر لما بدأت أرصد المقالات الناقدة
أو النقد الموضوعي للرؤية في ذيك الفترة لما أُطلقت
كان عدة نقاط، بس يمكن من الأشياء المشتركة والمتكررة
كان موضوع غياب المستهدفات المرتبطة بالتعليم
احنا نتكلم على مستهدف واضح في موضوع خدمة ضيوف الرحمن
مستهدف واضح في الخدمات اللوجستية
مستهدف واضح في تسهيل ممارسة الأعمال
مستهدف واضح في زيادة الإنفاق على الترفيه والثقافة
بس ما فيه شيء أبدًا عن التعليم العام
التعليم المدرسي في عدد المباني المستأجرة
وللا في ترتيب طلابنا في المؤشرات الدولية
أيش رأيك في موضوع مستهدفات التعليم
في وثيقة رؤية الأساسية؟
التعليم في الرؤية يمكن يتلخص في جهد واحد
أو توجه عام كبير جدًّا
لكن تحته فيه عدد كبير جدًّا من التفرعات
التعليم في المملكة العربية السعودية بدأ تركيزه
على أن هو يرفع مستوى محو الأمية في البداية
إلى أن وصلنا، الحمد لله، إلى محو الأمية
هذا الكلام أنا أتكلم من سبعين أو ثمانين سنة
وصلنا ولله الحمد والمنة، إلى أحد أعلى مستويات
القدرة على القراءة والكتابة في المملكة العربية السعودية
على مستوى مقارب لأفضل الدول في العالم
بعد كذا بدأ ينتج عندنا مخرجات تعليمية
ماهي مبنية على احتياجات سوق العمل
فالجانب اللي أخذته الرؤية من ناحية السياسة العامة في موضوع التعليم
هو الربط ما بين مخرجات النظام التعليمي
وإحتياجات سوق العمل، هذا هو المخرج الرئيسي
وتحت هذا تقدر تتكلم عن تفاصيل كثيرة ومتعددة
شفناها اليوم مترجمة في برنامج تنمية القدرات البشرية
يمكن من الأشياء الملفتة في رؤية السعودية 2030
واللي ما لقيتها في الرؤى الأخرى للدول المختلفة
هي موضوع برامج تحقيق رؤية
احنا عندنا إحدى عشر برنامج لتحقيق رؤية السعودية 2030
وهذا يخلينا نتساءل، كيف وصلنا لهذا النموذج؟
وأيش الحاجة لوجود هذا الجسم في النص
بين الجهة اللي وضعت الرؤية وبين الجهات التنفيذية
اللي بتنفذ الرؤية، الوزارات المختلفة
ليش ما خلينا المتابعة مباشرة منكم في مكتب الاستراتيجية
للوزارات المختلفة، أن كل واحدة تنفذ أهداف الرؤية
نشأت الحاجة هذه الحقيقة، يمكن من أمرين رئيسية
كانت ملاحظة في ذاك الوقت واحد
واحد، لم يكن لدى الوزارات التنفيذية المختلفة
قدرات التخطيط الاستراتيجي أو قدرات التخطيط المالي
التخطيط كان يتم من خلال وزارة الاقتصاد والتخطيط
في الخطط الخمسية
والتخطيط المالي كان يتم من قِبل وزارة المالية
عن طريق ورش عمل الميزانية اللي بتتم بشكل سنوي
فما انبنت عند الوزارات هذه القدرات
كان فيه حاجة لجسر أو آلية لرأب هذه الفجوة، هذا واحد
اثنين، كنا بحاجة ماسة لتعزيز العمل التشاركي من بين الوزارات
البرامج يرأسها لجان برامج
يجلسوا عليها جميع الوزراء المعنيين
بتحقيق أهداف أي برنامج
بتلاقي البرامج هذه هدفها
جسر ما بين مركز الحكومة وما بين الوزارات التنفيذية
ولكن هذا الجسر يحتوي على الممكنات الرئيسية لرأب هذه الفجوة
لو تكلمنا عن الإسكان مثلًا، تتكلم على أن فيه الوزارة
في ذاك الوقت وزارة الإسكان
وفيه وزارة البلدية كمخزن أراضي
فيه الصندوق العقاري كممول
فيه البنوك أيضًا كممول من القطاع الخاص، فيه المطورين
كل هذولي اللاعبين المختلفين
أنت محتاج أحد يرتب وينسّق جهودهم ويتابع عملهم
هذا كان واحد من أدوار برامج تحقيق الرؤية
بكل تأكيد. وقس على ذلك في كل البرامج الثانية
أي برنامج بتمسكه بتلاقي فيه كل من يؤثر أو يتأثر
بأعمال هذا البرنامج؛ جالس على الطاولة
ورأيه مسموع في صياغة خطة التنفيذ ومن ثم متابعة التنفيذ
من الملفت في موضوع برامج تحقيق الرؤية، أنها دائمة التغيير
احنا نتكلم على موجة أولى من البرامج
منها اثنين أو ثلاثة اختفت، برنامج تعزيز الشخصية الوطنية
برنامج ريادة الشركات المحلية و...
بعدين أُضيف برنامج أو برنامجين
برنامج تنمية القدرات اُستحدث لاحقًّا
برنامج التحول الصحي اًستحدث لاحقًّا
فيه برامج طلعت من التحول الوطني مثل التحول الصحي
وفيه برامج اُستحدثت من العدم
مثل تنمية القدرات أو شيء مثل كذا
فليش فيه تغيير مستمر؟
وفيه طبعًا برامج تم تغيير مسماها
مثل برنامج التوازن المالي، صار اسمه برنامج الاستدامة المالية
ففيه تغيير مستمر، وفيه تحولات
الناس شوية يمكن تقلق من هذا الشيء
بأن ما احنا ماشيين مضبوط، أيش رأيك؟
أنا أعتقد أن هذا شيء إيجابي جدًّا
يعبّر عن ديناميكية وتجاوب للمتغيرات، هذا أولًا
في البداية كان السؤال، هل نصبر وما نطلّع أي برنامج
الين ما نجهز بمجمل البرامج ونطلع بها مرة وحدة؟
لكن إذا كان شيء جاهز، ليش يأخّره؟
جاهز ومستعد بالعكس ينطلق
واللي ماهو جاهز يكمل، ويمكن يستفيد من الدروس
اللي اُكتسبت من إطلاق البرنامج اللي قبله
فكان المبدأ من البداية، أن اللي جاهز يتوكل على الله
وما يستنى الباقيين، هذا واحد
اثنين، بعض الأمور تحتاج إلى بحوث أطول
بعض الأمور تحتاج إلى تعمق أكثر في التفاصيل
فأخذت وقتها إلى أن نشأت
الشغلة الثانية، ما في برامج أُلغيت، ما في شيء اختفى
الحقيقة، أي شيء ما تشوفه اليوم كبرنامج
فهو موجود ضمن برنامج آخر
برنامج تعزيز الشخصية الوطنية اللي تكلمت عنه
اليوم موجود كجزء لا يتجزأ من برنامج تنمية القدرات البشرية
فموجود المستهدفات كلها، موجود المبادرات كلها
ولكن تحت إدارة مختلفة وشكل مختلف
هذه الديناميكية بالعكس أنا أشوفها شيء إيجابي جدًّا
ويعبّر عن قدرة على التجاوب مع المتغيرات المطروحة
فيه تغيرات محلية وفيه تغيرات إقليمية وفيه تغيرات عالمية
ففيه لجنة اليوم استراتيجية
هذه اللجنة العليا اللي تتابع الرؤية بشكل عام
وتتابع برامج تحقيق الرؤية
فيه برامج تحقيق الرؤية تتابع مع الجهات
تتصمم المبادرات وتتابع تنفيذها
وتدعم القصور فيها مع الوزارات
فهذا اليوم هو شكلنا
السؤال، كيف نتابع مسيرة الرؤية؟
وأيش طبيعة علاقتكم كمكتب استراتيجية وكلجنة استراتيجية
مع هذه البرامج ومع الجهات المختلفة؟
تكلمنا عن مراحل الرؤية الثلاثة
المرحلة الأولى، كانت مرحلة التأسيس
وهذه مرحلة يمكن كانت أصعب مرحلة
في مرحلة التأسيس كان تركيزنا الأكبر
على إيجاد آليات التنفيذ وتمكين هذا الجهات
بعد كذا بدأنا التركيز على عملية متابعة الأداء
لما بدأت تنطلق البرامج تباعًا
بدأ التركيز على موضوع متابعة الأداء
وكانت الآلية المعتمدة في وقتها تقارير ربعية
تُكتب من قِبل مكتب الإدارة الستراتيجية
بناءً على معطيات من البرامج
بناءً على معطيات من مركز قياس الأداء العام
وتُجمع في مكتب الإدارة الاستراتيجية
يُقدم تقرير ربع سنوي للجنة الإستراتيجية
ثم لمجلس الاقتصاد والتنمية عن هذه الرؤية
وتلى ذلك تقرير سنوي، في نهاية كل سنة
يطلع تقرير برضه لمجلس الاقتصاد والتنمية
تقارير حقيقةً متعمقة جدًّا تنظر إلى أكثر من جانب
أول شيء، كانت تنظر إلى الأداء العام للرؤية
بعد كذا تنظر لأداء البرامج وتقارن ما بين أداء البرامج
حتى بعضها والبعض الآخر
وبعد كذا تنظر إلى أداء المبادرات
ثم تنظر لأثر ذلك على المؤشرات والمستهدفات
فكانت تقارير معمقة جدًّا
وإذا لاحظنا أن برنامج معين يحتاج للتدخل أو يحتاج إلى دعم
هذا هو الوقت المناسب أن نقدم الدعم ونقدم التدخل
مين مبدعين؟ ومين جايبين العيد؟
شوف التقارير هذه أنا أتذكرها، أول ما بدأت أطلع
كانت مبنية على نظام إشارات المرور دائمًا
كله أحمر
اللي هو أخضر، أصفر، أحمر
إيه
في البداية كان كله أحمر، صدقًا كان كله أحمر
هم يدّعون أنه شغلة ميزانيات، بحاجة ميزانيات
مو شرط أنه ميزانيات، أحيانًا عدم قدرة على القياس
المعلومة ماهي متوفرة أصلًا
خط الأساس ما وُضع، المؤشر لسه ما اكتملت أركان قياسه وما إلى ذلك
و في البداية كان فيه صعوبات كبيرة جدًّا في تمويل هذه المبادرات
الفكر اللي مطروح في الرؤية مختلف تمامًا عن الفكر السابق
آليات التمويل المطروحة في ذاك الوقت
لا تتوائم مع هذا الفكر
فكان فيه حاجة لإيجاد آليات تمويل بديلة
آليات تمويل الرؤية إلى اليوم مختلفة تمامًا
عن الأنظمة الحكومية المعتادة
لكن الجميل بدأنا نشوف «فوائد عَرَضية» لهذه الأمور
لذلك أول ما وضعت الرؤية، كيف نموّل؟
كيف نقدر نبدأ نطرح عرض وطلب في السوق؟
كيف نقدر نتعامل مع الباعة بطريقة مختلفة وما إلى ذلك
فنشأت الحاجة لإيجاد آليات تمويل الرؤية
هذا كتيب طويل جدًّا ومعقد، يساعدنا أن نموّل البرامج هذه
بعدين نشأت الحاجة أن احنا نعمّم هذا الأمر
على القطاع العام بالكامل
فصار تحديث لنظام مشتريات المنافسات الحكومية
وقتها أنا أتذكر، احنا كمكتب استراتيجي لعبنا دور في هذا الموضوع
أن نحرص أن أي شيء موجود في آليات تمويل الرؤية
لازم ينعكس في نظام المشتريات والمنافسات الحكومية
بحيث يمكن المستقبل ممكن ما نحتاج هذه البرامج
نحتاج أن الجهات التنفيذية نفسها
تتعاقد بآليات حديثة ومبتكرة تساعد على التنفيذ
وأظن هنا يبان دور مركز الحكومة
في أن يطبق أهدافه في كل السياسات
فمثلًا في نظام المشتريات الحكومية الجديد
صار فيه تركيز على تمكين المنشآت الصغيرة والمتوسطة
اللي هي أحد الأهداف
والمنشآت الوطنية
والتركيز على المحتوى المحلي كأولوية في المنافسة
وتركيز على آليات التعاقد المختلفة
فأنا أبغى أشارك القطاع الخاص، أبغاه يجي ينفذ بعض المشاريع
ثم ينقلها إلى الحكومة اللي هي «بي بي بي»
شراكة القطاعين العام والخاص
هذه كلها اليوم منعكسة في نظام المشتريات
لأن مركز الحكومة هو اللي يفكر ويخطط
وليس جهاز واحد من ضمن الأجهزة المختلفة
فهذه تعتبر من التحولات والثمار لوجود مركز حكومة فعال وقوي
في الحقيقة، هذا تمثيل واقعي لسؤالك السابق عن ليش أحتاج برامج؟
احتجت البرامج عشان أعمل جسر ما بين الواقع وما بين المأمول
بعد كذا الجسر هذا يصير جزء من آليات العمل الطبيعية اليومية
ونظام المشتريات والمنافسات الحكومية
يمكن مثال جيد على هذا الأمر
واحنا اليوم أبو عبدالله، نتكلم على نصف الرحلة تقريبًا
سبع سنوات عدّت وباقي سبع سنوات
أول شيء، هل هذا منعطف تقيسون فيها أنفسكم؟
وسواءً إيه أو لا، أيش أبرز ما تحقق في الفترة الماضية
على مستوى مستهدفات الرؤية؟
طبعًا منتصف الرحلة بالنسبة لنا ماهو المنعطف الحقيقة
احنا الرؤية بالنسبة لنا ماهي مقسمة إلى نصفين
وإنما إلى ثلاثة مراحل رئيسية
فاحنا الآن نعتبر في منتصف المرحلة الثانية بشكل أو بآخر
المكتسبات اللي تحققت كثيرة جدًّا
أو يمكن صعب أن أنا أتكلم عنها، يمكن الناس تحس
احنا سقراط كله يتكلم عن كل وحدة منها بشكل مختلف
بس نبي نسمع منك بصورة شاملة أو عامة
صدقًا يا عمر، يسعدني أقول لك
أن العالم كله يتحدث عنه وليس سقراط بس اللي يتكلم عنها
أقصد كل حلقة تغطي شيء، ولكن العالم بالتأكيد يغطيها
الجميل حتى السردية العالمية في هذا الموضوع
تغيرت بشكل كبير جدًّا، وأصبحت فيه كثير من الإيجابية
أصبحت كثير من الدول تستقي الدروس من السعودية
احنا كنا في البداية نروح نجيب أفضل الممارسات
اليوم لو تشوف الدول الأخرى أيش بتسوي
كثير منهم يقولون أيش السعودية بتسوي
وهذا مفخرة بدون أدنى شك
لكن خليني أمر بشكل سريع جدًّا على الإنجازات
اللي صارت في السنوات الماضية والمكتسبات
نمسكها على مستوى المجتمع الحيوي
هنا نتكلم عن الخدمات الأساسية: الصحة، التعليم
نتكلم عن السكن، نسبة المساكن كانت في حدود 47%
واليوم نتكلم على أكثر من 60%
تغطية الخدمات الصحية في المناطق النائية
كانت 84% واليوم وصلت إلى 94%
من ناحية التعليم، المملكة كانت لا تقدم خدمات رياض الأطفال
من خلال التعليم الحكومي
اليوم صرنا نقدم الخدمات هذه ولله الحمد
ووصل نسبة الالتحاق برياض الأطفال
ما بين المواطنين في المملكة إلى 33%
هذا إنجاز عظيم، والله الحمد
لما نجي نتكلم على الفرص اللي موجودة في البلد
سواءً على مستوى الفرص الاقتصادية والتجارية
أو حتى على مستوى فرص التطوع
الناس تبغى تساعد وتبغى أن هي تدعم هذه الرؤية
بدأنا في عام 2016 بـ 23 ألف متطوع
اليوم نتكلم عن 658 ألف متطوع
2770% ارتفاع في نسبة التطوع
فالواضح بالنسبة لنا، أن الناس كانت بس محتاجة
أحد يحدد لها الوجهة ويمكّنها من التوجه في هذا الطريق
نتكلم على أشياء مثل قطاع الترفيه والرياضة والسياحة
نسبة السعوديين الممارسين للرياضة كانت 13%
اليوم نتكلم على 32%
فمستهدفات كلها، الحمد لله، تتحقق وكثير منها
نتجاوز المطلوب فيها
لو ننتقل على مستوى الاقتصاد المزدهر
طبعًا في بداية الرؤية
أهم مستهدف للرؤية يمكن هو تنويع الاقتصاد السعودي
ووصولنا أن نكون ضمن أكبر خمسة عشر اقتصاد في العالم
العام الماضي، ولله الحمد والمنة، الاقتصاد السعودي
كان أسرع الاقتصادات نموًا على مستوى مجموعة العشرين
بدأت إصلاحات هيكلية كثيرة ومتعددة
لفتح قطاعات اقتصادية جديدة ما كانت موجودة في البلد
نتكلم عن سياحة، ما كان لها وجود في البلد
نتكلم عن ترفيه، ما كان له وجود في البلد
نتكلم عن تعدين، ما كان له وجود في البلد، وقس على ذلك
طبعًا، القطاعات الاقتصادية هذه
سرعتها في البدء مختلفة من واحد لآخر
السياحة كانت بسيطة جدًّا
أفتح التأشيرة وأبدأ أجهّز البنية التحتية؛ الناس تبدأ تجي
فكان سهل وسريع أن احنا نشوف التحول
الترفيه، المواطن موجود وراغب في الترفيه
فكان سهل أن احنا نوفره ونشوفه بشكل سريع جدًّا
فيه قطاعات أبطأ قليلًا بطبيعتها
مثلًا خلينا نتكلم عن التعدين
آخر استبيان صار على البلد، ومكامن من المعادن فيها
أعتقد كان في الخمسينيات إذا ما كنت غلطان
اللي هو المسح الجيولوجي
المسح الجيولوجي هذا يأخذ سبع سنوات عشان يكتمل بحد ذاته
فاحنا إذا بدأنا في 2016، أخذنا بعض الوقت للتجهيز وما إلى ذلك
واليوم احنا نتكلم في المراحل الأخيرة، إن شاء الله
لإكتمال هذا المسح، وبعد كذا تبدأ فعلًا
وشاهدنا في نفس الوقت هذا إعداد نظام التعدين
تجهيز البنية التحتية لاستقطاب شركات التعدين
وخلق الشركات الوطنية الكبيرة في المجال هذا
لما نتكلم على ناتج محلي، إجمالي المملكة ارتفع
من 654 مليار دولار إلى أكثر من تريليون دولار اليوم
هذا بحد ذاته وإنجاز، وإن شاء الله، في طريقنا
أن نكون من أكبر خمسة عشر اقتصاد في العالم
إيراداتنا الغير نفطية، نتكلم عن تضاعف متكرر للموضوع هذا
من حوالي 160 مليار لأكثر من 400 مليار
بالنسبة لصادراتنا الغير نفطية
ارتفعنا من حوالي 18% أو 19% إلى 25% كنسبة من الصادرات
وصول صندوق الاستثمارات العامة من 600 مليار إلى 2.6 تريليون ريال
طبعًا مشاركة المرأة في سوق العمل
هذا أحد المنجزات الكبيرة للرؤية صراحةً
اللي ارتفعت من  23% إلى اليوم وصل 35% عدت مستهدف 2030
والآن محتارين أيش المستهدف الجديد
اللي مفروض يكون موجود على الطاولة
نسبة البطالة، أحد أهم الموشرات الاقتصادية في أي اقتصاد
احنا، الحمد لله، ارتفعنا من نسبة بطالة 12% - 8%
قريب جدًّا من الحد الأقصى لنسب التوظيف في أي بلد في العالم
وقريب لهدف 2030 اللي هو 7%
قريبة جدًّا من هدف 2030
وإن شاء الله، أنا أتوقع أن في المجال هذا
كمان بنحتاج نرفع المستهدف بعض الشيء
بإذن الله
وقبلما تروح أنت لوطن طموح
أنا أبغى أعلّق على موضوع رياض الأطفال
أنا كنت مستثمر من قطاع التعليم عشر سنوات، من 2008 - 2017
فجزء من البحث اللي سويناه قبل ما ندخل في الاستثمار
اطلاع على الخطة الخمسية التاسعة للسعودية
اللي كانت من 2010 - 2014
هذا كلام لا أنقله عن أحد، أنا اللي قريته بنفسي
كان المستهدف زيادة نسبة التحاق السعوديين في رياض الأطفال
أحد مستهدفات الخطة الخمسية التاسعة، وكذلك الثامنة
والحقيقة أنه ما تغير هذا الرقم أبدًا
يمكن هذا مثال حي لمدى فاعلية البرامج
في تحقيق المستهدفات
الهدف كما تفضلت ماهو هدف جديد
هدف موجود يمكن من خمسة عشر سنة قبل بدء الرؤية
لكن اللي صار لما وضعت البرامج
وفُتح المجال للعمل التشاركي والعصف الذهني
ومحاولات إيجاد أفضل الطرق لتحقيق ذلك
أنا أذكر وزارة التعليم جات بفكرة مبتكرة جدًّا
لبدأ هذا العمل بشكل أسرع من غيره
ومن خلال الاستفادة من المنشآت التعليمية القائمة
بدل ما أصبر ثلاثة، أربعة، خمسة، يمكن عشرة سنوات
عشان أنشئ بنية تحتية جديدة
عندي بنية تحتية في بعض الأحيان غير مستغلة
استغلوا الموضوع هذا في البداية
وهذا كان شرارة ممتازة لبدء التغير في هذا الموضوع
بالإضافة إلى ذلك، عندنا قدرات بشرية ممتازة
في وزارة التعليم، ولله الحمد والمنة
بدأنا نستفيد منها ونوسّع النطاق
لذلك ما بنينا شيء جديد، وإنما عظّمنا الاستفادة من الموجود
وشفنا النتيجة بشكل سريع جدًّا
وإن شاء الله، القادم أفضل في هذا المجال
بإذن الله، هل تحب تقول شيء في محور وطن طموح
أو ننتقل للي بعدها؟
أنا أعتقد المحور هذا من الصعب أنا أتكلم عنه، العالم كله يتحدث عنه
اليوم المملكة حضورها العالمي في صناعة السياسات
اللي تؤثر على البشرية؛ واضح وجلي للكل
قدنا قمة عشرين في وقت عصيب على العالم
والحمد لله، وضعنا بصمتنا على الأجندة العالمية في المجال هذا
دورنا المحوري في استقرار أسواق الطاقة
قائم ومستمر وتعاظم، ولله الحمد والمنة، في الفترة الماضية
بالنسبة لقيادة العالم العربي والإسلامي
كان لنا دور محوري في محاربة التطرف والإرهاب
إثراء الفكر الاجتماعي والثقافة الإسلامية
اليوم الزوار المعتمرين في المملكة
الحمد لله، بنحقق أرقام قياسية سنة عن سنة
هذا واحد من المستهدفات اللي أتوقع أن احنا بنتجاوزه
قريب جدًّا إن شاء الله، وراح نضطر أن احنا نراجعه قريب بإذن الله
الله يقويكم
أبو عبدالله، انتقل لمحور مهم متعلق بتحديات تنفيذ الرؤية
من الأشياء اللي أنا أكتشفها مؤخرًا ومنبهر فيها
هي موضوع الوصول اللي نحققه في سقراط مع الجمهور الخليجي
بس في الأسبوعين الماضية، تواصلت مع أصدقاء
من قطر، الإمارات، الكويت، عُمان، يتكلمون عن متابعة حلقات سقراط
والانبهار بقصة المسؤول الفلاني، الملف الفلاني، القضية الفلانية
ففيه متابعة لقصة التحول السعودية
على مستوى خليجي عربي وأوسع من ذلك
فأزعم أن جزء من هؤلاء يهمهم معرفة التحديات
كيف تعاملنا معها؟ قد يكون هناك دروس مستفادة
نقدر نهديها لكل المتابعين لقصة التحول السعودية
فأيش ممكن نحكي عن أبرز التحديات؟
الدروس اللي استفدناها لما جينا نبدأ رحلة التحول هذه من الدول الأخرى
اليوم المملكة صارت يمكن مدرس لتجارب التحول الأخرى
التحديات كثيرة جدًّا ومتعددة
أول شيء، صعوبة أن أنت تنتقل من طرح تقليدي إلى طرح مختلف
فيه درجة عالية جدًّا من الالتزام والشفافية
هذا نقلة نوعية
يمكن التحدي الثاني، كان تعزيز ثقافة العمل التشاركي
الناس بطبيعتها يحافظون على صلاحياتهم
ويحاولوا دائمًا أنهم يحققوا النجاح لوحدهم
الرؤية فرضت العمل التشاركي على الكل
وأسلوب سمو الأمير، الله يحفظه، فرض هذا الأمر على الجميع
كان فيه تحديات في الموارد البشرية كبيرة جدًّا
القطاع الحكومي كان فيه شيء من الترهل
وعدم القدرة على استقطاب الكفاءات
لما بدأنا الحوار، كنت أقول لك أن أنا لما جيت أشتغل في الحكومة
كنت متردد جدًّا
اليوم الشاب يتخرج من الجامعة
خياره الأول أن يروح يشتغل في الحكومة
القطاع الخاص يعاني صعوبات في منافسة القطاع الحكومي
على استقطاب القدرات
فكان فيه تحدي كبير جدًّا في إيجاد الكفاءات والقدرات، وتغيير الفكر
وتقبّل أن يكون فيه تنوع كبير جدًّا في طبيعة القطاع العام
الجميل أن التحدي لما يُنظر إليه كفرصة ويبدأ يُعمّم النجاح
يصير هذه نقطة قوة، بدل ما كانت نقطة ضعف
تتحول إلى نقطة قوة عندك
إذا كنا نتكلم على تحدي في استقطاب للحكومة في ذاك الوقت
اليوم أنا أزعم أن القطاع الخاص هو اللي عنده تحدي
في الاستقطاب بدل الحكومة
تضحك عمر، تمثل القطاع الخاص؟
يعاني منكم كثيرًا كثيرًا
نحتاج نحقق، واللي بنحققه ما بنحققه لنا، بنحققه للبلد
القطاع الخاص ما عنده الأموال الهائلة اللي عندكم
فهل المنافسة عادلة على المواهب؟ على المثال هذا
بالعكس، إذا كبر الاقتصاد؛ الكل يكسب
القطاع الخاص يكبر، والموارد المالية تتسع أكثر وأكثر، إن شاء الله
وهي ربما تكون هجرة مؤقتة، أقصد في نهاية المطاف
بتبدأ المواهب تتوزع بشكل سلس
فأزعم أن فيه نمط عملي براقماتي شديد جدًّا في تنفيذ الرؤية
اللي هو ما في حل مثالي
فيه حل له أعراض جانبية، له تكلفة معينة
لكنه حل مطلوب ننفذه ونتعامل مع الأعراض الجانبية ونحاول نعالجها
فيمكن هذه هي اللي اليوم نقدر نستشفها
أن فيه كثير من الحلول ليست مثالية
ولو بستنى حل مثالي، ما سويت أبدًا الإجراء هذا
ففيه ثمن لانتقال هذه المواهب للقطاع الحكومي
بس أظن فيه ثمن أكبر لو القطاع الحكومي
حاول ينفذ الرؤية هذه بدون هذه المواهب
بدون أدنى شك
ولا ننسى سوق العمل مثله مثل أي سوق آخر
مبني على العرض والطلب
لما جاء القطاع الحكومي وصار عنده طلب كبير
بدأ يأخذ شيء من الكفاءات من القطاع الخاص
لكن اليوم بسبب وجود الطلب هذا؛ العرض صار أكبر
فصارت الجامعات تركز أكثر أن هي تخرّج ناس
متوافقين مع متطلبات الطلب
سواءً كان من قطاع خاص أو من قطاع عام
فاليوم بنلاقي تركيز أكبر على القدرات المطلوبة لتنفيذ رؤية 2030
فبالتالي، بيزيد العرض، إن شاء الله تعالى
وكلنا بنكسب كاقتصاد بصفة عامة
هذا يمكن من أبرز التحديات، موضوع المواهب
فيه تحدي آخر نقدر نحكي عنه؟
التحديات كثيرة، مرة صعبة أن أنا أحصرها
بس الجميل في الموضوع أن احنا ننظر للتحدي
نواجهه بشكل مباشر، ونتقل إلى اللي بعده
ما ودي أركز كثير على التحديات
أنا أعتقد أن التركيز على التحديات مثبّط بعض الشيء
أنا أعتقد أن تركيز على الإنجازات هو الأجمل
وأيش أهم الدروس اللي خرجنا بها بعد هذه السبع سنوات
اللي تلخص حكاية التحول للسعودية؟
أول شيء، فيه فكرة علمنا هي سمو الأمير، الله يحفظه
أن أنت ما بتقدر تعرف حجم إمكانياتك إلا لما تجرب
فبدأنا أن احنا نضع طموحات عالية جدًّا
في البداية تبان مستحيلة، لكن مع الوقت يبان أن هي قابلة للتحقيق
فهذا كان درس عظيم
أتذكر المقاومة للمستهدفات العالية في البداية
أشوفها اليوم كيف صارت شأن عادي جدًّا نتعامل معاه
أعتقد إذا فيه دروس مستفادة
من التحول في المملكة العربية السعودية
نحتاج وضوح في الرؤية في البداية
لذلك يحتاج توجه عام مكتوب وواضح
يستطيع أن يقرأه المواطن
يستطيع أن يقرأه المستثمر محلي أو أجنبي
يستطيع أن يفهمه الدول الأخرى؛ عشان يعرف احنا فين رايحين
هذا أهم ميزة فيه، أنه ما يصير التنفيذ منوط بشخص واحد
كل من مهتم سيحاول أن يساهم في هذا العمل
فهذه وحدة مهمة جدًّا بالنسبة لنا أعتقد
الشغلة الثانية، ماهو كفاية أن أنت تحط رؤية
وماهي نهاية الطريق، هذا مجرد البداية
موضوع يأخذ وقت ويحتاج إلى عمل مستمر
وعزيمة وإصرار وديناميكية كبيرة وقبول للتغيير
يمكن الدروس الأخرى المستفادة
من السهل جدًّا على الدول أن هي ترضى بمستوى معين
إذا كان المستوى هذا مقبول
لكن الأفضل للدول هذه ولبقية البشرية بصفة عامة
أن احنا ندفع حدودنا أكثر من ذلك
اليوم القصة التحولية السعودية ماهي بس للسعوديين
اليوم كثير يتابع هذه القصة
ويحاكيها ويبغى يتعلم منها
فلو نبغى نلخص لهم أهم الدروس
اللي اليوم نقدر نشاركها مع العالم، أيش بتكون؟
يمكن أحد أهم الدروس المستفادة من رؤية المملكة 2030
أن التغيير يبدأ من رأس الهرم، التغيير يبدأ من فوق دائمًا
وأفضل طريقة لرأس الهرم أن هو يمكّن التغيير هذا
ويحشد كل الجهود نحوه؛ أن يكون فيه وجهة واضحة
الكل يقدر أن يبدل ما يستطيعه من جهد للوصول إلى هذه الوجهة
الشغلة الثانية، أن هي ماهي بس رؤية ونقعد نستناها تتحقق
وإنما توضع الرؤية، وهي بداية العمل وبداية الجهد
والجهد مستمر ما يوقف
يمكن الدرس الآخر المستفاد بالنسبة لنا بشكل كبير جدًّا
واللي أتمنى أن يمأسس ويرسخ في أعمال الحكومة بصفة عامة
هو الديناميكية وقبول الحاجة للتغيير
ما في رأي واحد صواب للأبد
وإنما الرأي صائب في وقته، وممكن أن يقبل للتغيير
وشفنا مثال على ذلك، التغيير اللي شفناه في البرامج
وخروج أشياء جديدة
الديناميكية هذه تأتي من المسح المستمر للأفق
وإيجاد الفرص أو مواطن الضعف اللي يبغى لها تحسين
خليني أضرب لك مثال
الرؤية مثلًا لم تتكلم أبدًا عن ألعاب إلكترونية
في وقت ما طلعت في ذاك الوقت
صحيح
لكن مع الوقت لاحظنا أن هذا القطاع
أحد أسرع القطاعات نموًا في العالم
المواطن السعودي بصفة عامة
نسبة الشباب فيه عالية جدًّا وكلهم يجيد الحاسب
وشغوفين بالألعاب الإلكترونية
توفر بنية تحتية، اتصالنا بالإنترنت
بالضبط. هذه كلها كانت فرص
الجميل في الرؤية أنها كانت ديناميكية بشكل كافي
أن هي تشوف فرصة بهذا الشكل
وشفنا إطلاق استراتجية الألعاب الإلكترونية مثلًا
على إثر ما رأيناه من فرص في هذا المجال
بتلاقي دائمًا فيه رغبة في اقتناص الفرص الجديدة
فهذا كمان أحد الدروس المستفادة
لا نتوقع أن الأمر مستقر في حين وبيستمر لخمسة عشر سنة
أتذكر أول ما بدأنا نكتب الرؤية ذيك الأيام
كان  فيه كلام عن المدى الزمن للرؤية
هل يُعقل أن أحد يخطط خمسة عشر سنة قدام؟
احنا ما نعرف أيش يصير في العالم
لكن ميزة أن أنت تحط مستهدف بعيد الأمد
وتحرص أن أنت تكون ديناميكي وتتجاوب مع المتغيرات
أنك فعلًا بتحقق هذا المستهدف بهذه الديناميكية
يمكن العمل التشاركي والمأسسة
لأن العمل الغير مؤسسي قد يكون نافع جدًّا
لكن نادرًا ما يكون مستدام
موضوع التشاركية، احنا أقوى مع بعض
وهذا جزء من روح الرؤية
ليش فيه وثيقة اسمها رؤية؟
لأننا نبغى الكل يتشارك في مساعدة الوطن
للوصول لهذه الوجهة
يمكن هذه بعض أهم الدروس المستفادة في رأيي
ولو بنتكلم على موضوع المأسسة في العمل أو العمل المؤسسي
يمكن ماهو بهذه الصورة اللي واصلة للناس
الناس تشعر بأن فيه وزير يدخل بالملف على الأمير محمد
يوريه الأهداف حقته، يعتمدها الأمير
وينطلق الوزير هذا في العمل
فيه عندنا حلقة سابقة مع الأمير «تركي بن طلال» أمير عسير
حكى عن الرحلة الطويلة لاعتماد استراتيجية عسير
فلو نسلط الضوء شوي، بما أنك ذكرت أنها من الدروس المستفادة
على سالفة المأسسة
فيه انطباع أن مركز الحكومة هو إدارة الخيمة أو شيخ القبيلة
فيه أحد يدخل يأخذ مباركة وموافقة وينطلق
بينما اللي أنا أعرفه أن الأمر مختلف تمامًا
هل تقدر تسلط الضوء على بعض الأمثلة، الحكايا في هذا الاتجاه؟
هذا أمر متكرر كثيرًا
أول شيء، سمو الأمير محمد حريص أن بابه مفتوح
عشان يقدر يسمع ويقدر يتجاوب مع الناس
لكن موافقته في اللقاء فردي
حتى هو دائمًا، الله يحفظه،  يؤكد على هذا الأمر
كوني وافقت لك على هذا الأمر؛ لا يعني أن هذه الموافقة الرسمية
الموافقة هي مباركة، هي اتفاق مع التوجه أو شيء من هذا القبيل
لكن العمل المؤسسي يستلزم على الوزير المعني
أن هو يرفع من خلال القنوات المعتمدة
لذلك موافقة سمو الأمير هي مباركة للتوجه
لكن هذا ما ينفي أبدًا الحاجة للرفع، هذا من ناحية
من ناحية ثانية، تشوفها في كل الأمور
اللي تحاول الحكومة أن تتحققها
من خلال رؤية المملكة العربية السعودية 2030
دائمًا نحرص على أن نبني جهة مرجعية، نمكّن الجهة المرجعية
نحرص أن الجهة المرجعية هذه تعمل بطريقة مؤسسية
أول شيء، متوافقة مع التوجه العام
اثنين، مبني على استراتيجية تفصيلية
وفيها خارطة الطريق وفيها آليات للوصول للمستهدفات
ومراجعة مستمرة لهذه الأمور دائمًا
نسمع الكلام هذا، لكن أقدر أأكد لك من الداخل أن ماهو صحيح
لو أخذنا مثال لوحدة من الاستراتيجيات
حتى لو بغيت تسميها أو ما بغيت تسميها
لدورة حياتها داخل مركز الحكومة
عشان نقدر نفهم شلون تمر هذه الاستراتيجيات وعلاقتها بالرؤية
لأن الاستراتيجيات هي الشيء اللي الآن بدينا نشوفه بكثرة
استراتيجيات مناطقية واستراتيجيات قطاعية
ممكن تعطيني مثال أو دورة حياة؟
ممكن جدًّا. طبعًا الرؤية لما وضعت مثل ما قلت لك
وضعت الرؤية، ثم وُجدت البرامج اللي غطت الأهداف الاستراتيجية
بعدين من خلال المراجعات المستمرة؛ لقينا فجوات
فيه أشياء ما غطتها البرامج، أو ما غطتها بشكل كافي البرامج
ما بتوصلنا للمستهدف المأمول
بدأنا نجمع هذه الأشياء كلها ونشوف أيش الاستراتيجيات القطاعية
لأن الاستراتيجيات القطاعية هو أسلوب التخطيط المؤسسي
المتعارف عليه
أنت كنت تتكلم عن البرامج قبل شوية
وأن هي جسم دخيل، هي فعلًا كان جسم دخيل
كنا نحتاجه في 2016
اليوم نمت القدرة على الإنجاز
لدى الجهات التنفيذية والوزارات في البلد، بشكل كبير جدًّا
فصار فيه حاجة لوجود استراتيجيات قطاعية تقودها الجهة القائدة
لما نجي على استراتيجية الاستثمار بتلاقي تقودها وزارة الاستثمار
لكن يتشارك في تنفيذها جميع الوزراء المعنيين
نتكلم عن استراتيجية الرياضة واستراتيجية المناطق
منطقة عسير أو المناطق الأخرى في المملكة
بنفس الآلية تقريبًا
دورة حياتها تقريبًا هي نفس دورة حياة البرامج
هو نفس العمل المؤسسي، ولكن بشكل آخر
فأنا أزعم أن هذا بيكون أسلوب التخطيط
في المملكة العربية السعودية بالمستقبل، بإذن الله
فهي تبدأ من نفس الجهة القائدة، وبعدين...
لا
من وين تبدأ؟
تبدأ من مركز الحكومة
مركز الحكومة يحط التوجه
ويعمل مع الجهة القائدة على الاتفاق على المستهدفات
وبعدين الجهة القائدة تجمع الجهات
اللي تحتاج أن تجمعها وتشتغل معاها
تضع خطة لتحقيق هذه المستهدفات
وبعدين ترفع لمركز الحكومة للمراجعة والموافقة
في مركز الحكومة تمر بعدد من دورات المراجعة
سواءً من قدرتها على تحقيق المستهدفات
التوافق مع باقي البرامج والاستراتيجيات اللي موجودة
وبعدين فيه أشياء ما بتتحقق من مبادرة وحدة
أو مستهدف واحد أو برنامج أو حتى من استراتيجية قطاعية
وإنما جميعهم مشتركون
خليني أتكلم عن الناتج المحلي الإجمالي مثلًا
كل مبادرة من مبادرات البرامج
أو الاستراتيجيات القطاعية أو الاستراتيجيات المناطقية
تصب في الـ «جي دي بي» هذا
فعشان أقدر أن أصير اقتصاد رقم خمسة عشر
أنا أحتاج كل هذه الجهود مجتمعة
وأنا طبعًا ما أقدر أختم هذا اللقاء
بدون ما أغطي جزئية أنا والآلاف غيري
شغوفين فيها ويتطلعون لها ويستمتعون بسماع المزيد عنها
اللي هي شخصية الأمير محمد بن سلمان
أنت في هذا السنة تُكمل عشر سنوات من العمل مع الأمير محمد
قائد استثنائي، في لحظة تاريخية
ليس فقط المجتمع السعودي
حتى المجتمع الدولي ينظر له بتقدير مختلف
فنبغاك تحدثنا عن هذا الرجل، أيش تعلمت منه؟
سمو الأمير تعلمت منه كل ما أعرفه اليوم
الأمير محمد قاعد استثنائي
الله أكرمنا به في هذا البلد، في هذا الوقت
الحقيقة الكلام عنه يصعب جدًّا
وصعب أن ألخص عشر سنوات من الانبهار في حوار قصير جدًّا
لكن الأمير محمد عنده مجموعة من الصفات الاستثنائية في زعمي
وخلينا نركز عليها
أول شيء، عنده وضوح شديد في التوجهات
دائمًا عارف أيش يبغى
الشيء ثاني، إذا حدد اللي يبغاه واتفقنا عليه
فهو عنده إصرار شديد جدًّا على الوصول لهذا الهدف
لكن مصاحب لذلك ديناميكية كبيرة جدًّا في قبول التغييرات
اللي لا يمكن التعامل معاها
فهذه الثلاثة مع بعض، في زعمي، إن شاء الله تعالى
هي اللي بتوصلنا لتحقيق رؤية 2030
بس إضافة إلى ذلك
سُموّه، الله يحفظه، عنده قدرة جميلة جدًّا
على النظر في الصورة الكبرى ومن ثم الدخول في التفاصيل
ومن ثم الرجوع للصورة الكبرى ومن ثم الرجوع في التفاصيل
لذلك وقت ما نحتاج للصورة الكبيرة؛ بتلاقيه مركز على الصورة الكبيرة
ويتجنب التفاصيل، والعكس بالعكس
هذا شيء مبهر،  حتى لما تشوفه في العمل
كل الناس اللي يشوفونه في العمل ينبهرون به دائمًا
عنده قدرة عجيبة، الله يحفظه ويرعاه
على الفصل ما بين المواضيع
من الصعب جدًّا أن أنت تدخل في اجتماع
يتكلم عن أمور أمنية وعسكرية وبعدين تخرج
تدخل في اجتماع يتكلم عن أمور صحية أو اجتماعية
ترجع تدخل تتكلم في سياسة دولية أو مشاركات عالمية
ترجع تدخل في أمور اقتصادية
وبدون ما يؤثر أحدها على الآخر
هذه الحقيقة من الأشياء الجميلة جدًّا
اللي أتمنى أكون تعلمتها من سُموّه
من الصعب أن أنا أسويها على نفس المستوى
لكنني دائمًا منبهر بها
وما أزال انبهر بها اليوم حتى بعد هذه السنوات كلها
أنا لما أرجع وراء إلى السبعينيات وأفهم أيش صار
ما ألقى جواب واضح
احنا فجأة كنا في بيوت طين
أو والدي يحكي يقول أنه كان في بيت طين
بعدين صار في بيت مسلّح
كان يتنقل بالساعات من مدينة للمدينة
بعدين صار فجأة يتنقل بالطيارة
فيه قصة تحولية صارت في السبعينيات
بس ما نعرف كيف صارت
و لما أسأل أبوي كيف صارت؟ ما عنده جواب
لو سألك عبدالله، في 2030 كيف سوينا اللي سويناه؟
ستعزو ذلك لأيش؟ أيش بيكون جوابك لسر
أو سبب قدرتنا على تحقيق الرؤية؟
مجددًا أعتقد هو الأمير محمد بن سلمان
لولا هذا الرجل الاستثنائي، ما أعتقد أصلًا كان ممكن نفكر
في الأشياء اللي بنفكر فيها اليوم
الرجل هذا كان عنده وضوح في التوجه
كان عنده عمق في الفكر، وإصرار على التنفيذ
تمكين كبير جدًّا مع الاحتفاظ بحقه للمسائلة
أعتقد هو الرجل اللي صنع الفرق، بكل صدق و أمانة
شاكر ومقدر لك أبو عبدالله، إتاحة هذه الفرصة لي
أني أوثّق هذه الرحلة التاريخية لهذا الجيل
والأجيال القادمة عبر هذا الحوار
فشكرًا لك على قبول الدعوة
أشكرك عمر، وجهدك حقيقةً مساعد كبير جدًّا للرؤية
واحنا حريصين، إن شاء الله، أن هو يستمر
وإن شاء الله تعالى، نشوفه محفز للجميع
أن هو يحرص على الاهتمام بالرؤية
وتنفيذها في المستقبل القريب
بإذن الله تعالى، شكرًا لك أبو عبدالله
شكرًا عمر
ممتن لك
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لفهدة القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
ياسر آل غانم في إدارة التصوير
مسؤول إضاءة سالم بافقاس
وعمر عبدالمجيد مساعد في الإنتاج
وفي تصوير الكواليس عبدالرحمن عبود
وفي تسجيل الصوت يوسف إبراهيم
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج
غيداء التميمي وأيمن خالد وأصيل بافرط
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
اشتركوا في القناة